welcome back thank you very much our our
second panel is going to probe more
deeply into how we live and work with
fair use built around those four factors
and by the way on your program you will
see on the very back page the full text
of the fair use statute now for all the
things you've heard about fair use all
those things are rooted in that statute
that barely fills the equivalent of a
half a page of text so there's the root
of what is fair use and that's what
gives us the factors that we've referred
to a few times for how we work with fair
use and make decisions and so our second
panel brings different observations and
ample experience from working inside
different organizations where they are
called upon on behalf of themselves
their own organization on behalf of
clients through the law firm to answer
questions about what is fair use how do
we work with fair use what might our
standard be and so our three speakers
Cherie Carter Gavin from from counsel's
office at Yale University Bob clara de
practicing attorney here in New York
City and represents many organizations
that that we are akin to and Gretchen
Wagner from art store all of these folks
are attorneys and are going to bring
that attorney perspective as well but
they're driven by many other motives so
so let me bring them up and I think
we're going to do them in the order we
have so sorry come on up well it is
certainly my pleasure to be here to
discuss with you a particular
perspective in applying fair use the
composition of the panels today really
reflects that fair use is applied in
numerous context and really should be
understood from a number of different
perspectives I thought I might give you
a glimpse into the perspective that
apply when we apply fair use in the
context of OpenCourseWare I'm sure many
of you are familiar with OpenCourseWare
MIT in 2002 launched its MIT
OpenCourseWare initiative and as part of
that initiative and my teammate
available class notes syllabi all sorts
of resources related to actual courses
taught at MIT and MIT made all this
content available under a Creative
Commons license in fact they use the
attribution share-alike non-commercial
license which is a very liberal license
that allows the user not only to access
the material on the site or view the
material on the site but users were able
to modify this content create derivative
works based on this content and then
further disseminate this content
downstream when Yale Oh initiated its
OpenCourseWare initiative yell open Yale
courses it thought about doing something
a little bit different what Yale
ventured to do was create audio visual
recordings of all the lectures of
specifically identified courses and to
make those audio visual recordings as
well as transcriptions of those
recordings reading materials and the
typical OpenCourseWare type of content
available through its open Yale courses
website and similarly Yale pursued a
creative commons attribution share-alike
non-commercial license so this presented
a bit of a nightmare from a rights
clearance perspective we were dealing
with a Content third party content
embedded in this new educational
material was trying to set free on the
world and we really were not quite sure
how we're going to address rights
clearance in fact the OpenCourseWare
providers that
came before us had taken the position
that fair use might not apply in the
open courseware context and we knew that
there was a lot of fear involved in
applying fair use there's a saying that
goes that the worst thing you can do in
life is to constantly live in fear of
making a mistake and that's where we
were librarians faculty members those
who are managing collections throughout
our university and in fact legal counsel
were feeling very apprehensive at the
time we're regarding to with regard to
applying fair use but I think one of the
things that came out of our experience
is that we almost had to experience what
it would be like not to apply fair use
when we should apply fair use to
understand when fair use should apply
which brings me to this first slide the
slide this slide is the first slide the
opening slide to a modern poetry course
taught by our esteemed faculty member
Langdon hammer and the course reads in
some instances materials that were
projected on the classroom screen are
not shown due to copyright restrictions
so who do you think played a role in
that slide okay so that's to say okay we
the General Counsel's office we do make
mistakes too so this was the opening
slide and what was the kind of content
we were referring to when we said some
of the materials that were projecting
projected on the classrooms screen were
not shown going to give you a little bit
of an example
I imagine that you all have images of
Robert Frost and actual images in your
mind when you when you when you think of
this poet he's a familiar face in
American literature and I gathered some
of them that seemed representative here
here is this is crossed in old age as an
American barred from a magazine this is
this is the frost if you probably have
to know is if you were born with white
hair right and a kind of well kindly and
monumental and yet approachable figure
that is familiar from American school
rooms here's a another image of that
same guy requested by Grandma clocks
reminding us of frost as a kind of link
to 19th century life to to rural Vermont
another another image of froth I'm just
a little story president Hales bond with
frost that President would be John F
Kennedy on TV he extolled poet who
called new frontier age of poetry and
power and perhaps you have seen images
of frost and reading his poem the gift
outright at Kennedy's inauguration it
was a powerful moment in American
culture where the president allied
himself at poetry in this way Oh more
pictures this is you know Frost with
Grant Thornton trusted his pet calves
okay so he was kind to animals I'm going
to stop here I showed this clip to my
children and they were outraged they
asked where are the images where are the
pictures it was very disturbing for them
to see this this video and I'm sure it
will
is disturbing to many of our users
professor hammer is trying to make a
link between Robert Frost the man and
his poetry and he's attempting to create
context in which the students can
understand Robert Frost he's he's
attempting to revive an image of Robert
Frost in the students mine professor
hammer shows approximately ten images in
the first 20 minutes of this lecture
none of which you can see okay we made
other decisions of this kind when
OpenCourseWare first launched decisions
like not showing a PowerPoint
presentation that contained an image of
a map or not including certain poetry or
requiring that the lecturer really break
up the poetry in a way that may have not
pedagogically made any sense in order to
make sure that we were in fair use when
the poem was being recited and then
transcribed for OpenCourseWare in fact
one thing we also did is we cleared
rights to use a particular translation
of the Bible and it was a very very
difficult process and that kind of
process kind of makes you start thinking
well what if the rights holder said no
could we not show this material could we
not teach our population about the Old
Testament or not refer to this content I
mean it was it was pretty pretty absurd
but we were alone in making these types
of choices and I think we reached a
point of desperation because we knew we
were compromising the experience almost
like what Brandon was referring to in
terms of compromising your mission you
always have to keep in mind what are we
trying to do here and is this working
and I would say this was not working and
we were fortunate
at the same time we were having these
struggles MIT and other course where
providers were having these struggles
and we reached out to PETA yazzie and
Patricia off de Heidi and elicited their
help in creating a code of best
practices for OpenCourseWare and we
created a number of different scenarios
and you've heard what this process is
about we reached a consensus and we we
even debated some of the issues which i
think is very healthy about well really
is this right is this the right thing to
do should fare you supply in this
context should we should we request
permission and we also made sure that in
having these conversations we were also
considering some of the options getting
creative common Commons content actually
clearing the rights in one instance we
entered into a contract with a provider
of musical content so that we can play
as much as music as we wanted in as many
contexts as we want it without having to
go through a fair use analysis because
of the fact that it was just too unclear
to us and we weren't sure of a comfort
zone but what Peter and Patricia helped
us do is have a conversation that took
us out of this fear based analysis into
a rational based analysis and by having
that kind of discourse we were able to
find what I call is our comfort zone
with regard to fair use and in a comfort
zone is not legalese but I think part of
what we should be doing in talking about
fair use is create a user friendly way
of applying fair use we need to talk
about fair use in ways that people can
really understand and really apply and
within this comfort zone you want and
this is sort of a weary i recast what we
did in the code because it was an easy
tool for me to use and sometimes i think
we all have to think about how do how is
it best that i can under
this concept and so within the comfort
zone was for the purposes of
OpenCourseWare the use of third-party
content for illustration or
demonstration and explanation or
critique or analysis and we we wanted to
encourage those uses within our
community within the academic academic
community we believed all of these types
of uses of third-party content was
transformative and we thought that it
was helping us further our mission and
further quite honestly the purposes of
fair use and the free the First
Amendment purposes of fair use and
outside of that comfort zone with things
in me you can't see some of the bubbles
but use of content for entertainment
purposes and that happens I think people
love to use content even faculty members
love to use content and sometimes though
you know they'll run a cartoon you know
they'll put up you know something to
make the to relieve the tension in the
class and that may or may not be of fair
use I think what's outside the comfort
zone I would say are not necessarily
uses that are not fair use I think their
uses maybe that are more risky or uses
that might be out of the comfort zone or
the comfort zone of my institution one
thing I really want to encourage is I
want everyone in this room who's not a
lawyer to recognize that the lawyers in
your institution are actually there to
provide advice and you know it's they're
busy I'm busy um but I think it may make
sense to share some of your ideas about
fair use and to start the conversation
with your legal counsel and have a
productive conversation about the kinds
of things you wish to do and how you
want to fear to to apply fair use so
that you can come up with a common
understanding within your respective
institution because institutions have
their own cultures and
they also have their own sensitivities
about risk and that's what happened
actually out of our code of best
practices for OpenCourseWare Yale was
lucky because I participated along with
my colleague who's here Pamela chambers
in developing these scenarios that that
ultimately resulted in the code but at
the end of the day I had to discuss this
with my general counsel and she had to
bless the code and in some instances you
can get a blessing and with some
reservations sometimes you'll get well
you know what I still want you to come
back to me when you want to do X or want
to do y and I think by having those
conversations maybe that can relieve
some of the nervousness about being out
there alone making these decisions and
assuming risk on behalf of your
University and I don't want to hear
every case you know I don't want to hear
I don't want to get um besieged with
requests and questions about this fair
you supply in this context or just fair
you supply in that context and that's
not what happened in the context of
opencourseware in fact I we created the
code and we pretty much stepped away and
when there was an issue when I knew oh
there was a class that was being
presented that had a lot of content of
some type particularly creative content
what we do is we pass the code on to the
faculty member you'd say read this
digest this and let me know if you have
new questions and maybe this will be
your guide in knowing how fair use would
apply in your particular context now we
had a special problem with with
OpenCourseWare and I'll call it the
elephant in the room and the elephant in
the room was how to address fair use for
copyrighted material incorporated into
content licensed under creative commons
and it's true in all likelihood if
whatever the end user did was really the
end users problem but we wanted to act
responsibly and I think it goes a long
way in your relationship with rights
holders generally to make reasoned
decisions and to behave fairly even if
there's no law that's requiring you to
do so so what we did for OpenCourseWare
is we make sure that we made every
attempt to attribute when reasonably
possible we didn't just take third party
content slap it up there and say well
it's fair use and it's instructional
Lord's illustrative or we're
demonstrating a concept in fair game but
we made sure that what we could we let
the user know where this content came
from and instruct them user that
actually you know you can't take that
poem that we just described and do
whatever you want with it you have to
make some judgments on your own and
that's our responsibility to make sure
you understand that not in all instances
could we attribute the content because
OpenCourseWare isn't a publication in
the typical sense this is OpenCourseWare
contains material that faculty members
pull together gathered sometimes on a
whim without any thought about having to
publish or disseminate and in some
instances we couldn't figure out where
this stuff came from and in those
instances we couldn't attribute but what
we did do is we try to put in a little
language in our Terms of Use it says you
know if you know of any information
regarding our material let us know so
that brings me to a final final bit and
that regards the different tools we have
at our disposal when copyright doesn't
do justice to what we have to do fair
use is a great tool I think it's
wonderful but I also think that we need
to start asking our federal relations
people to really fight hard for
changes in the copyright law and start
carving out protective areas for us
internet service providers have some
protections when there are materials on
their sites that really don't belong
there and they can walk away and no harm
no foul and I think we need to start
thinking about what kinds of
improvements we need to seem a copyright
law and fighting for those changes and
one colleague of mine at another
university I asked her well what do you
do when you know you don't for example
you're dealing with off orphan works you
think fair you supplies and it probably
does but you want to be fair reasonable
and you don't know who to call or what
to do she says well we put in
information that says if you know if you
have rights of this material please send
us an email let us know let's have a
conversation we have that same issue at
the vine aqui houses many many images
and some of the images you know we
purchase these images or there we there
they're donated to us and these
collections have so many rich images and
we might don't know where they came from
who the copyright older is but that
doesn't necessarily mean we're not going
to make this material available but we
do have some language it says if you if
you have information let us know and at
least in a couple of instances we've had
rights holders come back to us and say
that that's mine and then we say well
look at what we're doing isn't this
great and sometimes and they say in all
cases they say yeah that is great thanks
you know just make sure you you
attribute me as the owner so I'm sure
we'll hear more and this has been I
cannot tell you how delighted I am
because the information we're hearing
today and the perspectives are very very
rich and I very much appreciate
participating today
alright thank you very much and it's it
is really wonderful to be here and I
have a number of clients in the room
today I do work with a number of
universities and libraries and nonprofit
institutions of all kinds who have these
issues on a regular basis and what I'm
going to try to do is to just sort of in
a very abstract way sort of walk through
the process that I would use with a
client who comes to me and says is this
a fair use the question about is it a
fair use of you know there's some some
grumbling some understandable grumbling
about why can't we ever get a straight
answer is it fair use or not is it fair
use as a question is sort of analogous
to is it going to rain tomorrow you can
often have a pretty good idea but you're
never going to be completely sure and
then there are some situations in which
you really even wouldn't want to try to
guess because it's just a toss-up so the
facts are always incredibly important
and what I'm going to be talking about
her some general principles that apply
pretty much no matter what your facts
are first of all I don't like to think
about these questions in terms of is
this a fair use or is it not a fair use
it's a bigger question that the question
is my institution wants to do a
particular activity is it a safe thing
to do or a risky thing to do how safe is
it how risky is it because ultimately
what you're going to decide is either to
do the activity not do the activity or
change your plans a little bit to make
the activity a little bit safer fair use
is part of that analysis but it's
certainly not the entirety of that
analysis the first thing I would ask in
every case and this has come up a couple
of times already is is there a contract
in place because if there's a contract
in place if your licensing from a
database let's say and you've got terms
and conditions that you've agreed to
those terms and conditions will govern
and there is case law that says if a
contract takes away your fair use rights
that's enforceable folks that's an
enforceable contract people can contract
away any rights they may otherwise have
under the Copyright Act if you're a
copyright owner you're contracting away
your exclusive right to distribute the
work and if you're a copyright user you
may be contracting away certain fair use
rights so you have to be really careful
and when you're doing these negotiations
you often don't have an awful
a bargaining power you get pretty much a
contract of adhesion these are our Terms
take it or leave it and that's a very
bad position to be in but once you've
taken it it's going to be difficult in
some cases to argue oh but it's a fair
use anyway if if the agreement is really
written in a very draconian and and
detailed away you may not have a lot of
fair use left to argue about second
issue that always comes up is and this
is all in the in the category of risk
analysis or risk management there's
always some risk and your question is
how do you how do you best manage it is
the copyright owner going to know you're
doing this very often they don't if
you're putting something up on the web
you can be sure they will find it but if
it's not up on the open web many many
times the copyright owners will never
know how likely is it that this is going
to be a you know a public issue if
you're doing something on a large scale
you have to assume probably it's going
to happen but somebody comes to you can
I do this in my class on Tuesday
probably nobody is ever going to know or
care second question is if the copyright
owner does know that it's happening
would they care enough to want to sue
you about it odds are probably know
particularly if it's one of these sort
of day-to-day kinds of questions that
come up about something that's going on
in a classroom if you're digitizing a
whole gigantic collection and putting it
on the Internet yes they might care
enough to sue about that there might be
enough of an incentive but you know bear
in mind that all the costs that are
associated with litigation for your
institution are also associated on the
plaintiff side it's not free for
plaintiffs to bring lawsuits and very
often they don't bring lawsuits even
when they have good clean I represent a
lot of plaintiffs to and very many times
my clients choose not to sue for various
reasons one being that it gives them a
black eye if they're going to sue this
you know wonderful public-spirited
institution that they don't want to be
the black hats in that scenario and also
it costs a lot of money and they're
probably not going to get it back the
Copyright Act does have be shifting
provisions in it that if a copyrighted
work is registered before the
infringement commences fees can be
shifted to the prevailing party that is
the
the loser will have to pay the winners
fees but that's discretionary with the
court and it doesn't happen as often as
you might think and particularly if you
have a pretty good fair use argument and
you're a non-profit institution the odds
of a plane of recovering attorney's fees
in that situation are pretty low so it's
a very large cost to a plaintiff to
proceed with a lawsuit as well so you
have to factor that in there's a sort of
a climate of fear I think that people
have that copyright owners are just you
know waiting to swoop down and an attack
and that's that's generally not the case
there there are some who are obviously
more aggressive than others then you
have to think about what is the cost of
if if a lawsuit were to be commenced and
you were to lose what would the cost be
to the institution certainly the cost of
defending it is large and probably you
would have outside counsel rather than
in-house counsel of the University if
your work in a university handling the
litigation that would be a large expense
and that's certainly not something to
take lightly against that cost you then
have to think about well what are the
costs of avoiding a lawsuit what are the
costs of Licensing the material in the
first place I was just in a discussion
last week for a client who's a big hotel
here in New York and they were talking
about oh well you know we want to do
this we want to have this art exhibition
we want to do this and that and we want
to put brochures okay well are we going
to you know is this a fair use no way is
this a fair use your hotel you want to
bring people in you're putting out
brochures to you know come look at the
art in your hotel it's a selling point
its advertising and so we're going back
and forth and you know the cost of
getting a license to do what they wanted
to do would have been a thousand dollars
$1,500 certainly less than the cost of
luring it for two hours so
taking a license may be a point of
principle sometimes I'm not going to
take a license I have a fair use you may
have a fair use but it may still be the
better part of valor to take a license
that's that's you know that's the way
that's the way disputes get resolved
very often is by compromise and that can
sometimes be a very attractive
compromise also you have to think about
are there other ways to to accomplish
what it is that you want to accomplish
and I'll use an example of a large
religious organization that I work with
and they were having a big national
meeting of people from all over the
country coming to this big meeting and
they had hymns that they wanted people
to sing and as you may know copyright
act has certain certain public
performance exemptions under 110 for
religious services but this didn't
qualify for that what they really wanted
to do and what they were asking me about
was can we photocopy and hand out copies
of these hymns so everybody can have the
hems and would that be a fair use and
start looking at that and say well gee
your nonprofit this and then you can go
through the whole fair use analysis but
ultimately there's a provision in
section 109 C of the copyright act that
says if the people are present at the
place where a copy is located you can
display a copy on a screen with a
projector like this and so you have one
copy it's a legitimate copy you put it
on an elmo and off it goes on to a
screen and everybody in the room can see
it no copies are made the public
performance is okay under 109 you don't
have to have the fair use argument I'm
not saying that would work for very many
circumstances at all but there are other
ways very often to get the result that
you're trying to get with with fair use
and sometimes a simple sort of
rethinking of the way you deliver the
content can make a big difference for
example people are hosting content on
servers now rather than putting the
content there they're allowing their
their their servers to be used by people
to to host content if you are a service
provider an Internet service provider
under the dmca you have no monetary
liability if you are hosting content
that is
air at the request of users and you can
respond to a takedown notice if and when
you get a takedown notice and that's a
lot easier than making a fair-use
decision about things that takes you
into a different business you're not
building a collection and presenting
your collection you're hosting material
from other from other sources but it's
it's it's something that certain clients
of mine have been thinking about to take
advantage of the DMCA because after all
a lot of times if you're looking for a
particular example in a scholarly
setting I teach I have a course here at
Columbia Law I'll find things on YouTube
I really do find things on YouTube and
YouTube is a great resource for things
that I want to talk about in my class
and YouTube is protected by the DMCA
because they're hosting this incredible
body of content so there are sometimes
ways that the technology can allow you
to avoid what would otherwise be a
pretty significant risk of copyright
infringement and then finally all of
these considerations about the cost of
litigating and with the copyright owner
care enough to sue you and all those
sort of things those are all costs and
and and you know negatives you have to
balance that always against the benefit
to the institution of doing the activity
it is after all a cost-benefit analysis
is not just a cost analysis so you have
to say what purpose is really being
served to this institution and to this
to the students the faculty to the
people who are part of this community by
doing this activity and if this activity
has a great public benefit from a lot of
these risks might be bearable and if the
if the public benefit is well you know
we want our students to have you know
easy access to movies on their iPads and
save them a netflix subscription that's
not a very good public benefit that's
not a very good institutional benefit
and that's the kind of benefit that you
know the in a fair use analysis would
would would not serve you very well if
you couldn't make a very good argument
as to why this is serving the purposes
of copyright another point thats related
to that is that in fair use cases the
optics the atmospherics matter all
lot in these copyright cases and you can
go through the list of the four factors
and you can look at judge lavalle's
article on transformative use and you
can understand that as well as anybody
in the world understands it and if what
you're doing looks like piracy you're
probably still going to lose your fair
use argument and there's an example of a
case of involving us again it was in a
religious context another nonprofit
religious organization that was
distributing books it was a splinter
group of a larger organization a larger
organization had published a book that
it was no longer circulating splinter
group takes the book and start sri
publishing and distributing at handing
it out free on street corners that's
just pure piracy that's taking somebody
else's work and reprinting it and giving
it away distributing it publicly they're
a nonprofit institution there's no
market harm because the plaintiff was
not selling this work anymore anyway the
plaintiff had withdrawn this work
repudiated this work was never going to
publish this work again no conceivable
market harm still it was not a fair use
because all you're doing is is taking an
existing work making copies of it and
giving it out to people that was not
something that was a compelling sort of
public benefit in a fair use context
also public benefit is not necessarily
the same as transformative use a
transformative use is a kind of public
benefit the public benefits from having
more speech more commentary about about
existing work you're making a new work
you're giving a work a new purpose new
message new meaning all that from Judge
laval's article but there's also a kind
of a public benefit that can come just
from keeping a work from disappearing
that's a public benefit as well public
benefit is a concept that comes up in
the legislative history of section 107
and in connection with with a project I
was working on involving film
digitization there's a great discussion
in the legislative history of section
107 that talks about it would clearly be
fair use to to make copies of films that
were deteriorating and you know to have
preservation copies that would that
would clearly serve a great public
benefit and
be you know be a great candidate for
fair use well that's not really
transformative in a way that's taking a
film and saving it so it can still be a
film you're not using it for a different
purpose it's still going to be the film
it is and you're going to watch it
because it is that film you're not
making a new work out of it you're not
really even putting it in a new context
but you're doing a great public benefit
of keeping that film from disappearing
so the concept of public benefit is
broader than judge lavalle's concept of
transformative use so when you think
about oh well the use we're going to
make here is not transformative because
we're not commenting on the work we're
not making a new work out of it you
still might be providing a great public
benefit and if you are you could still
have a very strong claim to fair use and
I think because of the time i will leave
it there and i'll be happy to take
questions after we open it up for the
floor so good afternoon to all of you
and thanks for so much for coming today
since the topic of today's discussion is
in large part about really how we roll
up our sleeves or at least this is how I
perceive the conversation how do we roll
up our sleeves as a practical matter and
rely on fair use and today in connection
with that kind of broad mandate I
started to think about what does this
mean for art storm what has it meant for
art store because we've relied on fair
use for the past ten years it's really
been a very critical component of our
fair use strategy so for those of you
who are unfamiliar with arched door it's
a nonprofit organization that was
founded by the andrew mellon foundation
to utilize digital technologies to
further research teaching and learning
and so within that broad mandate one of
the things that we do is to make
available and ever expanding library of
digital images for in the arts and
humanities and so the library right now
has about one and a half million images
with another one and a half million
images in the production queue that will
be made available over the next couple
of years and the libraries available in
tutions nonprofit institutions in 45
countries worldwide so to frame our fair
use discussion today I want to sort of
note not only have we been relying on
fair use for 10 years but we rely on
fair use for about twenty percent of the
images in the library right now at least
so it gives you a sense of sort of if
you're talking about and here I want to
knock on wood because I've become
superstitious since I've taken the job
of general counsel of art store but to
the extent that we are sort of the
canary in the coal mine there's there is
one way to sort of look at this question
so back when we started to look at
copyright issues ten years ago we
realized that given the scale of what we
were trying to accomplish of building
this ever-expanding library that would
meet educational needs and given the
what I call the kind of traditions
around images the traditions of
permissions around images we realized
that there was no way we were going to
be able to obtain permissions in every
instance so for starters as was referred
to earlier there are many many orphan
works in the image context particularly
with respect to photographic works and
non-western art objects and I could go
on and on where you just you can't
reasonably identify the copyright owner
but perhaps more importantly what we
understood after looking at this
question and frankly after undertaking
an initial permissions effort was that
there just aren't those traditions of a
sort of easy or efficient permissions
mechanisms in this context so you write
letters of permission you frequently
don't hear back and if you hear back
it's inevitably a conversation about
image quality and attributions and data
quality and while those are all fine and
productive and useful topics the point
is there's no way to sort of do this at
any kind of scale that would sort of
fulfill our broader educational mission
so we at that point started to really
look at very seriously look at fair use
and as the only way that we could
achieve our
occasional mission and it is because
that's the sort of basis for my gray
hairs today but back from 10 years ago
and we started this analysis because the
laws obviously at that point was so you
know it was sort of all over the place
on these questions in developing a fair
use strategy so one of the first things
we did was to better understand fairies
jurisprudence and we got the superb
assistance of bob clara de he is we are
one of his clients but the next thing
that we did was to develop what I call
an environmental scan and when you're
thinking about developing a fair use
strategy particularly you know so much
of us today are engaged in large-scale
digitization or distribution efforts and
particularly when you are when you're
involved in one of those projects I
think one of the initial steps that you
can take is to undertake this
environmental scan so what we did was to
look and see what other users were doing
in our context what are other
educational users doing are they
obtaining permissions are they not if
they are why are they doing that and we
also tried to understand what the
universe was of rights holders and what
were their concerns and so one of the
things that we uncovered in undertaking
this analysis was that first there was
this century long tradition of relying
on fair use in our context and I have to
just back up and say I wish at the time
we'd had one of these fair use
statements that Brandon and Peter and
Patricia have been involved in as we
were undertaking this environmental scan
because frequently these fair use
statements can give you a piece of this
environment they can sort of let you
know about what the sort of community
practices are and that can be
tremendously helpful as your sort of
starting this this sort of first point
of understanding the landscape and so as
Brandon so graciously noted earlier I
was involved in the development of a
visual resources association fair use
statement for the use of images for
teaching research and study and Bob was
on our advisory panel for that
and as was Virginia Rutledge who's
somewhere in the back of this room the
point of that was though really in part
to document community practices and so
when we were doing this for art store we
were able to point to these same
community practices so there was a
century long tradition of rolling on
fair use there were long traditions of
rights holders not challenging this
practice and not seeking permit not
seeking not trying to require that users
obtain permissions and so we were able
to document all of that I think it's
really important to note though that
even if there are not those same
traditions so even if there is a sort of
active licensing effort under being
undertaken by the community it's okay
still to rely on fair use you don't have
to point to those types of practices and
you don't have to point to sort of what
others are doing so that's the
parenthetical I have on that first point
that even if others are relying on fair
uses in certain ways and you're not you
may still very well be able to rely on
fair use this leads me to the second
point about developing a fair use
strategy and that is I found it
tremendously helpful when we were first
undertaking this effort to develop a
fair use or copyright statement that was
then posted on our website and the point
of this statement is really to lay out
the equities of what you're trying to do
so it's to put your fair use argument in
that kind of broader context or
framework it's to say here's the
background for why we're doing it it
sets the tone it says here is what we're
trying to accomplish and in part you're
trying to do that for the for the
community that you serve and part you're
trying to do it to get ahead of the
potential copyright plaintiff because if
they come to you as may be the case this
made this document may help frame that
frame the set of arguments that you have
and it may also help you demonstrate
good faith and here we talked earlier
about the for fair use elements I want
to argue today that they're now 5 and I
think good faith as bob was alluding to
earlier is really an important element
at this point so the optics as he said
matter and we're now seeing in a lot of
the recent cases you know certainly in
the Shepard Fairey case but in the
Carrie or the bill graham archives case
we're seeing courts look at the good
faith or lack thereof the of the
plaintiff or defendant so when you're
developing your fair use strategy one of
the things we've done it at art store
and one of the things that was pointed
out in the ARL and other statements is
we employed a number of mechanisms to
help demonstrate our good faith so we
use terms and conditions of use our
terms and conditions of use don't
preclude fair use but we used terms and
conditions of use we have digital rights
management technology we employ another
a set of provisions there that are
designed to protect the rights of
copyright owners and I want to note here
it's really important you don't have to
employ these things to rely on fair use
you don't have fair use doesn't require
that you have terms and conditions of
use or that you employ digital rights
management but what it does do is
potentially help demonstrate your good
faith so again to the extent that you
are trying to demonstrate good faith
that may be particularly helpful I I
think of these kinds of protections is
really being sort of reasonable
accommodations that don't hinder your
broader mission that are designed to
demonstrate that you are trying to be
respectful of copyright owners interests
the fourth thing I would say about any
fair use policy it
is to note that as was suggested earlier
it doesn't have to be a sort of all or
nothing approach so one of the very real
limits of fair use is its geographical
boundaries as probably most of you know
in this room fair use exists in the US
and I'm delighted to hear that there are
some efforts to push this forward in
other countries but as it stands right
now it really does not by and large
exist outside the United States and to
make matters more complicated when
you're distributing globally such as on
the open web the question of which law
applies is really an unsettled and kind
of murky one much to my horror when I
was looking at this so for art store
this is meant that when we distribute
the library abroad in some instances we
have a smaller library that we
distribute abroad we pull some images
we're relying on those images for fair
use in the u.s. we don't necessarily do
that abroad we also in some instances
obtain permissions from copyright owners
where and one of the reasons we do that
is because we want to be able to serve
educational users abroad so my point
here is that you can have a nuanced
approach to copyright and you're in your
policy it doesn't have to be sort of all
or nothing approach and in fact the law
is very clear that if you would go and
you try to obtain permissions from a
copyright owner and for whatever reason
those negotiations fail you may still be
able to rely on fair use with respect to
the work with that particular
copyrighted work so when it's it's a
nuanced approach to copyright and that's
and that's perfectly fine the next point
I'd want to make is you may have the
best fair use policy available and have
taken all sorts of protections and still
find yourself in a defensive posture so
not to say that we've done everything
right at art store but we make available
this library for limited purposes these
limited educational purposes I think of
them as being rooted in the First
Amendment we have
all sorts of protections in place and
yet we've had a handful of copyright
owners approaches with takedown notices
and so a couple of points here on that
um one of them I would say is that it
sounds kind of basic and simple but be
prepared ahead of time for that
conversation with the with the rights
owner so whether you're responding to a
letter or an angry phone call because it
may be your sort of only bite at the
Apple and you want to frame it in
positive terms as sure he was suggesting
earlier so you may be able to to really
turn around a conversation and we've had
a number of instances of that so one
example we had this person Donald
Woodman contact us he's a photographer
he's married to judy chicago and we had
cleared the rights to judy chicago's
works in the art store library but we
had not cleared his rights these rights
to the photographic works and the images
so he had photographed her her works and
he contacted us in italy and you know
it's one of those things those
monday-morning conversations you pick up
the phone and you wish you hadn't and
but you pick up the phone and it was
very uncomfortable initial conversation
by the end of the conversation he was
not only willing to keep his works in
art store but he wanted to make all of
his other works available and I think
it's fair to say that he and Judy
Chicago are now very supportive of art
store now it's not to say that you'll
always end up in that place you know
you're not going to always end up in
that happy that sort of happy spot and
when you don't you have to kind of make
that risk management analysis so you
know I say okay someone wants us to pull
we can't convince them not to pull so a
way the benefits and we say well what is
this with the impact on our users of
keeping it in the library and if we if
we pull what does this do in terms of
setting precedents on the other hand if
we don't pull the particular work what
does this mean in terms of our
relationship with this particular person
what does this mean in terms of other
relationships and obviously what does
this mean in terms of potential
litigation and might this leads me to my
next point which is that there are
really risks
parent in any approach so to put a
little bit of a finer point to this we
obtained permissions to include an
artist's work in the library through an
intermediary organization we were
subsequently contacted by the estate for
that artist who said I know you got
permissions and I'm not challenging
those permissions but I want you to take
the images out of the library and the
reason I want to take them out is I'm
developing a catalogue reason a of this
artist works and I'm afraid that the
having the works in art store will
somehow impact my catalog razon a
regardless of the merits of those that
copyright owners concerns this ended up
and still as a sort of risk management
analysis so we obviously weren't facing
that question of oh my gosh we may be
facing an infringement suit but we had
the same question at the end of the day
what is the impact if we take it down on
our users and what's the impact in our
relationship with this person with the
intermediary organization with others if
we leave it in so again same types of
risks you may also face risks by doing
nothing and you know Here I would just
emphasize with the rapidity of
technological change if you don't assert
fair use in some instances you may find
that a market developed in ways that's
not useful to you and so I would just
sort of keep that in mind as you're
thinking about all of your different
approaches and I think one of the real
values of the fair youth statements that
we're seeing that come out from Brandon
and his colleagues and from others is
that they are trying to sort of lay a
stake in the ground and say hey this is
really important and we believe this is
fair use and we're going to robustly
assert fair use under these
circumstances one other point I want
about making about mannat make about
managing your risks is in the sort of
mass digitization or distribution effort
so how many people in this room are
engaged in those kinds of large-scale
distribution efforts okay now how many
people really are engaged in then just
no I'm kidding so what I would say is
a couple of things one way of looking at
the copyright due diligence question you
know this has not really been discussed
I think enough and it's come up in the
orphan works context but I think we need
to spend as a community more time
thinking about this because one of the
ways we've handled this and it's not to
say it's necessarily the right way but
is to sort of put your content into
different buckets based on the risk
management analysis and to say okay we
think this set of content is the
riskiest this is less risky this is the
least risky and you spend your time
perhaps focused most on the bucket
that's the riskiest that being said I
think we really need to think about
advocating and art well articulating and
advocating for clearer due diligence
standards that take into account the
tremendous societal benefits of
large-scale digitization and that
recognize that there may still be ways
to recognize and sort of respect
copyright owners interests without sort
of undertaking an item by item due
diligence analysis it's just not
possible in these larger scale efforts
and that brings me to my last point
which is I want to urge us all to take
collective action working with entities
or individuals that are in similar
positions and here I think it's
important to take a look at all the
tools that are available to us certainly
the fair use statements are a really
important tool in that effort but I
think we should be looking at a range of
other of other actions and so I would
agree entirely with trees point about
you know trying to push for greater
legislation I think given where Congress
is these days I think that's writ large
I think that's probably unlikely but I
think we need to be thinking about
things we can do as a community and so
one option might be to think about you
know I was very impressed with the
documentary filmmakers statement and
their ability to obtain insurance
afterwards and so one thing I thought it
would be interesting is if we had some
collective financial support a sort of
fund for fair use litigation that
to us either in directly or indirectly
because one of the biggest challenges
facing all of us as Bob mentioned
earlier is the sort of cost of
litigation and therefore the cost of
being able to sort of robustly assert
fair use in ways you'd otherwise like to
the other point i would make and it's
more conciliatory is to say that i think
we should be prepared as an educational
community to work with rights holders
who want to meet us midway so i've
always been very impressed with places
like the Warhol estate or individuals
asserting Creative Commons licenses or
with museum efforts to make their
content more broadly accessible whether
it's for scholarly publishing or for you
know releasing public domain works so
there's a space there for us to work
with rights holders in meaningful ways
and I think being able to do so allows
us to then more robustly assert fair use
in other circumstances so with that I'm
going to turn great thank you thank you
very much valuable insights and we have
time for questions but just so it
doesn't get lost in the shuffle a big
round of applause for our first panel
and our second panel thank you
and and thanks to all of you and we'll
gladly have some questions wait wait
wait you had one in the first first time
let me let me hold off a little bit
questions questions new questions yet
somebody beat somebody hiding behind the
call I my interpretation of today's
conference and I found it very useful
and thank you to all the speakers was
that there's a lot of flexibility here
you know and a lot of the conversation
basically is just how much of a risk do
particular organizations want to take so
with that in mind especially since you
know we have the privilege of having
three lawyers here who actively deal
with these issues I was wondering if
anybody's particularly the lawyers could
provide more specific information on
just how frequent copyright infringement
lawsuits are um you know just how
frequently does that happen and how much
of a practice practical II speaking how
much of a legal risk really is there in
you know potentially more specifics
thank you that's an excellent question
you would give us an insight well yeah
thanks copyright lawsuits are not as
frequent as you might think a lot of
them get a lot of press particularly
there have been some high-profile
campaigns by the Motion Picture
Association in the recording industry
association that have gotten a lot of
attention the number of lawsuits filed
against libraries universities museums
nonprofits is vanishingly small you
obviously have the Georgia State
situation which you know took a lot of
people by surprise I took I told my
clients in the research library world
for about 15 years there has never been
a case brought against a research
library but
no now there has been so it's it can't
it's not that it can't happen but it
doesn't happen very often people who
have the copyright industries are really
being hit from all sides right now and
they have so many problems with a sort
of rampant commercial piracy and you
know online piracy of various kinds that
looking into what's happening within the
walls of university libraries is not a
high priority but I want to I want to
add to that what I've been seeing more
of is threatened legal action as opposed
to it materially materializing in any
real litigation and mostly from estates
because they're a little bit more
aggressive and have more of an emotional
stake I think sometimes in a real it's
not necessarily rationally based so
there is some clots costs from the legal
management side of just having to spend
time and energy negotiating and managing
those types of scenarios and I also
think it just depends on how deep your
knock it is and you know there are other
factors as well mm-hmm question yes
please now you say it really loudly I'll
paraphrase it
I i wish i wish i could have thrown the
microphone to you paraphrasing and and
paraphrasing and i'm going to try to use
a few of your words that that that that
university attorneys are the ones who
need some copyright education this is
this is our guest speaking and and and
that and that they are notoriously
conservative and need to be opened up
responses i think that's true to some
extent i think the role is to manage the
risk of the university so i think they
are responding to these issues from a
different vantage and i think is up to
the stakeholders to present their cases
and their needs to the General Counsel's
office and not be afraid to have the
dialogue that's necessary I don't think
it's necessarily a matter of being
educated as to the law but maybe being
educated as to your specific facts and
also educated as to really having a
conversation about the actual risk and
what are the chances and whether the
university may be willing to assume this
risk as opposed to retreat from it there
was something you said that triggered a
thought let me let me ask a slightly
slightly different question do you think
the university attorneys and again we're
grossly generalizing here do you think
that they are more conservative or do
you think they see the issues
differently I think they see the issues
differently and our conservative you
know because I me nuts are all of the
above you know but our role isn't really
to be free wheeling I mean that's not
our role I think you know that
librarians and people
who are involved in collections you know
they are playing a particular role we
play a particular role and we just have
to figure out how we can help each other
and so yeah I think we are conservative
because we have a big task in front of
us and that's to protect the University
and also protect the individuals inside
of the University we do get suit I mean
we do get nuisance you know we do have
two interfer eighth faced with and
manage challenging situations but I do
believe that what the statements these
codes have done is that they have at
they have provided legal counsel with
more information about what's actually
happening so that we can provide better
advice question right here yes please
that's right my time my bad okay
question for question I know that many
of our stores resources have sort of
complex copyright issues that they may
originate from one country but only by
another country and so I was wondering
you could whether you could explain how
you deal with the you know getting the
right to have those things posted on our
store it's a great question and so it's
true that we not only obtain images from
sources in a variety of countries but
then we also then as i said earlier
distribute in a variety of countries so
so much of what we spend our time doing
in obtaining collections for the library
is working with counsel to reassure them
that what we're doing is consistent
under the law I think it was a lot
harder when we started ten years ago and
in fact one of the first conversations
we had and this was not even with an
organization outside the US citizen with
one major university in the US I
mistakenly said to my boss I will go and
sit in a hotel room until this agreement
is signed I turned out to be a liar and
I would have been there for about two
years if the hotel de profited
handsomely from me so I think part of it
is the sort of a willingness of
institutions to rely on fair use or to
contribute to an organization like arts
store now that we've been doing it for
ten years I think there's greater
comfort in the field the other challenge
obviously comes from institutions where
you know there are not those traditions
of fair use outside of the US so frankly
we often have to provide indemnification
to move this forward and then getting
back to Bob's point earlier about so
much of fair uses the equities you know
I spent a lot of my time talking about
those equities with people and about the
optics and so I agree wholeheartedly
with Bob that
that certainly you can demonstrate fair
use through something being
transformative but it's certainly not
the only way and so we talk at art store
a lot about the sort of embedded First
Amendment interests inherent and what
we're trying to do and the societal
value of what we're trying to provide
but it's a conversation in every
instance we have time for a couple more
questions I see one over here and then
I'll come back to you yes please number
of us here today are from state
institutions and at one time I was under
the impression that you the state
institution had a certain amount of
protection in the Constitution on being
sued does it seem that that is not is
less so I mean I think that they tried
using that argument at Georgia State I
don't know if it's going anywhere just
wanted your impression about how much
protection one gets by being a state
well it is certainly the case that there
is sovereign immunity for state
institutions and that's constitutional
Supreme Court has spoken on it that
hasn't changed I think some state
institutions are reluctant to make that
argument it's not the first argument
that that you would you would have in
your brief although certainly not one
you would want to waive either and I
think that was part of the thinking
behind some of the institutions that
were early to participate in the google
book scanning project some of which were
state institutions and thought if worse
comes to worse we can rely on this
argument they also started with a fair
use argument though right that was where
they really wanted to have the fight but
I think they're there certainly is a
little bit of a safety net that state
institutions could have if a fair use
argument we're not successful Bob I
think I think that last point a little
bit of a safety net is is there is a
very important point I gave away my
microphone that that that that little
bit of a safety and that's important
because I mean correct me if I'm wrong
that whatever that Eleventh Amendment
immunity might be sovereign immunity it
doesn't it doesn't he
may mean that can still be a lawsuit
against individuals there can still be a
lawsuit for an injunction maybe
attorneys fees may be and there still
could be criminal action don't don't say
I have sovereign immunity I can do
anything I want because that's criminal
so there are limits to the protection
and there's I promise one last question
over here I've had various professors
come to me with requests for sort of
guidance or advice where to go questions
about the advisability of different
kinds of scholarship say someone has
written a history book and then they see
that electronic books are becoming in
fashion and how to go about that or
someone is going to write something
there in the middle of and they want to
know what their alternatives are perhaps
this would be a marvelous next topic for
a symposium on the alternatives but what
can be done pre and post in other words
looking back to gaining back rights of
something someone has written and making
sure that that work gets out there and
promulgated things the literature that
are in institutional repositories don't
always have that kind of acknowledgment
outside so those are my questions
basically well certainly if an author
has already published something that's
subject to a publishing contract that
will expire at some point presumably
maybe there's an out-of-print clause
that says if the work is no longer you
know selling more than X number of
copies a year then it goes out of print
and the author can get the rights back
something like that there are also some
provisions under the Copyright Act that
allow for a termination of prior grants
of Rights and older works so those are
the things that that an author can do to
get rights back once they've been
granted away but those are you know very
often you know not the sort of thing
that you can do
spontaneously you sort of have to wait
until you know the clock runs out on the
rights that are already in existence and
then do you sharee in working with your
faculty colleagues at Yale do you often
have questions about I have a
publication agreement for example what
are my choices do some of those come
your way I'm surprisingly no uh-huh I
think that our faculty need more
education on particularly the types of
contracts they should not be signing and
the types of rites they should be giving
away or retaining from them for
themselves but we don't get a lot of
those types of questions surprisingly we
get a lot more questions from the
librarians we will save that for the
next program and so on that happy note I
think we need to wrap up and I thank you
all very much another big round of
applause for all of our family fun
Brandon and thanks to all of you and
have a lovely afternoon